[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory
today i'm excited to be discussing the
major differences between the book and
film versions of drum roll please
harry potter
yes that's right today i'll be going
over the biggest variations between
harry as depicted in the novels versus
the movies right so as you may have seen
of the last few weeks i've released a
couple of other videos addressing the
book to film differences of other harry
potter characters specifically i've
shared my thoughts on the largest
discrepancies between the novel and
movie depictions of both hermione and
ron
and if you have yet to watch them i
encourage you to check them out and
share your thoughts with me in the
comments you can find both of these
videos right here on the harry potter
theory channel anyway for those of you
who have already watched the last couple
of videos on hermione and ron you may
have seen in the comments there were
quite a few requests for me to evaluate
the major differences between harry the
chosen one himself so without further
ado let's dig into it major difference
number one his overall attitude
when comparing the novel version of
harry potter to his counterpart in the
films one of the most noticeable
differences between the two is his
overall demeanor if you asked anyone
who's a fan of the books to describe
harry's character i'm willing to bet
that most of them would tell you that he
actually has a bit of an attitude
problem in the novels harry is
unapologetically sarcastic and he's
frequently getting himself in trouble by
being a bit of a smart mouth this is not
to say that the movie version of harry
doesn't get into his share of hot water
after all the main plot lines behind
each and every harry potter installment
is based on harry and the danger he
finds himself in but in the books the
trouble that harry gets into is
different somehow
novel harry seems to care very little
for the repercussions of some of his
actions a classical trait of
gryffindor's
whereas movie harry often seems like a
bit of a goody goody i'm sure every now
and again daniel radcliffe the actor who
portrayed harry potter in the movie
series delivers a bit of a cheeky line
or two and in these moments we see some
defiance speak out but where the movies
really lean into the angst and darkness
of harry's character the book showcased
him as a cheekier and more sharp-witted
young wizard
some fans have even gone so far as
sadeem novel harry as sassy and a bit of
a delinquent in the movies harry's
character also seems to be a little more
self-centered
he feels sorry for himself a lot more
and doesn't seem to really possess the
charisma of a natural-born leader like
he does in the books
major difference number two his magical
aptitude
in the movies harry is shown as being
magically gifted at most things almost
immediately
he's good or at least not bad at
basically everything he tries from
spells to flying
in the novels however harry's only
innate magical talent is his ability to
ride a broomstick he works hard for
everything else such as casting his
patronus and overcoming a boggart
as mentioned in my video about the
differences between novel and film ron
there's also the discrepancy between how
the two boys perform in school in the
books ron and harry both received
average marks but in the movies harry
seems to do much better in school than
ron
this creates somewhat of a problem in
the half-blood prince before in the
novels it's quite clear why harry needed
the notes written into the potions
textbook that he acquires by chance
in the film it doesn't make as much
sense why finding this text was so
beneficial to him
sure it makes him really awesome at this
class but it's more like he goes from an
a or b to an a plus
whereas in the novels the textbook saves
him from completely failing the class
major difference number three his
relationship with iran
another major difference which i also
brought up in my video discussing ron is
how the friendship between ron and harry
is portrayed
in the novels harry's best mate is
unquestionably wrong in fact in the
beginning of the book version of the
philosopher's stone harry doesn't even
like hermione he finds her annoying and
insufferable but in the movies he seems
to rely on his friendship with hermione
a lot more than he relies on ron this
may be because in the films ron is
depicted as kind of a buffoon and
hermione is the one with all the answers
so of course when dealing with serious
situations like defeating voldemort and
saving all of wizardkind it wouldn't
have made much sense from an audience
perspective for harry to seek advice
from ron whose only role in the films
seems to be comic relief we also miss
out on a lot of harry's relationship
with the weasley family as a whole
which of course impacts how his
friendship with ron is viewed
in the books harry spends a lot of time
with ron's family who embrace him
wholeheartedly while some of this can be
seen in the films it's usually harry and
hermione who are there not just harry
implying that it's not just harry and
ron who are super close but rather all
three friends major difference number
four his appearance
when it comes to the looks of a movie
character that's been adapted from a
book it's never going to be perfect
movies must deal with the process of
finding an actor who can play the part
while also keeping the novel's
description of the character in mind
i'm quite certain this ordeal is
somewhat of a nightmare in any case as
with the majority of characters who
appear first in books and later on in
movies there are some noticeable
differences between the look of novel
and film harry potter
of course both depictions of harry do
have his famous lightning bolt scar
naturally actor daniel radcliffe who as
mentioned earlier portrayed harry on the
big screen did not have this scar which
meant that the filmmakers were able to
choose exactly where to place it on
daniel's forehead however some fans of
the novels were upset upon seeing the
films since they had envisioned that the
scar was in the center of harry's
forehead however rest assured the scar
was where it was meant to be
as apparently it was jk rowling herself
who dictated where it should go on his
head
aside from the scar i suppose you could
say one other thing that's the same
between the two versions of harry is the
color of his hair
but in all honesty that's kind of where
the similarities stop
for the majority of the films daniel's
hair is pretty neat and tidy which is
not how harry's hair is described in the
books
in the novels his hair is said to be
wild and messy which i do concede they
kind of got right in the prisoner of
azkaban film
in any case at least they got the colour
right throughout the entire movie series
which is more than can be said about his
eye color
novel harry's eyes are well known to be
bright green
just like his mother's lilies
this detail of harry's appearance is
touched on many times throughout the
books
so it seems like it would have been a
given that whoever portrayed harry in
the films would also have a green eyes
even if that meant wearing coloured
contact lenses or something
and yet daniel radcliffe's harry potter
had clear blue eyes
well as it turns out daniel is allergic
to coloured contact lenses
so that option was out and i suppose for
such a small superficial part of harry's
appearance it didn't make sense to look
into any other options
the last difference between book and
movie harry's looks comes down to his
physique
quite honestly this doesn't bother me
too much since really how could you find
the perfect physical representation of a
character described in a book
but while we're on the topic of
differences i suppose i should admit
that i envisioned harry to be quite a
bit skinnier than he was in the films
and that's not to say that daniel
radcliffe isn't in shape rather daniel
just wasn't quite as thin and sharp in
appearance as i'd imagined harry would
be
as in the books he's described as having
knobbly knees and a thin face
neither of which are attributes of
daniel's
and with that we've come to the end of
another video
what did you think do you agree with the
differences i've suggested or have i
missed any major ones
let me know your thoughts in the
comments below and as always if you
enjoyed this video don't forget to like
it and subscribe to the channel until
next time remember
it does not do to dwell on dreams and
forget to live